gesellschaftlicher Frieden und
Stabilität sind in Gefahr wegen
Inflation gasknappheit drohender
Rezession Krise ist wie so schön heißt
die Stunde der Exekutive der Regierung
und die nimmt die allererster Linie
finanzielle Herausforderung voll an für
manche Zufall denn der Schuldenberg
wächst in schwindelerregende Höhen
Bazooka Wumms und doppelwumms wer soll
das bezahlen jetzt in der Phönix Runde
Phoenix Runde
hohe Energiepreise und Knappheiten auf
der Angebotsseite bescheren uns
Inflationsraten die viele in unserem
Land noch nicht erlebt haben und die
Inflation wird sich nicht nur auf der
Einnahmenseite des Staates zeigen
sondern auch auf der Ausgabenseite der
Staatshaushalte eine Auswirkung haben
soweit unser Bundesfinanzminister heute
bei der Bekanntgabe der Steuerschätzung
es wird ja 126 Milliarden Euro
mutmaßlich geschätzt mehr geben bis 2026
aber was da in der Staatskasse dann drin
ist das kommt auch ziemlich schnell
wieder raus zu diesem Thema oder zu
diesem Aspekt werden wir später mehr in
der Sendung noch diskutieren und damit
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
Philipper Siegel Glück da ist bei uns
mitbegründerinnen und Direktorin des
Dezernats Zukunft
Institut für makrofinanzen also im
Wesentlichen Staatsfinanzen öffentliche
Haushalte sie haben auch im
Bundesministerium für Finanzen
gearbeitet unter Olaf Scholz die waren
sogar Finanzministerium im
westafrikanischen Liberia und auch bei
der Weltbank haben sie schon gearbeitet
professor Michael eilford ist Vorstand
bei der Stiftung Marktwirtschaft
und Daniel hier schon ausgehen die haben
vor zwei Jahren das traditionsreiche
Thüringer Unternehmen Carla Porzellan
übernommen und die Porzellanherstellung
bringt es mit sich dass dort sehr viel
Energie vor allem sehr viel Gas
verbraucht wird schließlich Klaus
ulferscheid Berlin Korrespondent der
Süddeutschen Zeitung Herr hier
schonowski wir haben gesagt die
Produktion ihren Betrieb ist gefährdet
der Standort carla ist gefährdet wie
sieht das denn im Moment aus in
Anbetracht des Winters hat der Betrieb
noch gute Überlebenschancen also ganz
konkret freuen wir uns natürlich
momentan über die niedrigen Preise die
an der Börse aufgerufen werden es ist
sozusagen schwindelerregend in die
andere Richtung heute war der Preis fast
Null das heißt Gas wurde fast verschenkt
in Rotterdam das sorgt natürlich in
erster Instanz erstmal dafür dass man
denkt juhu es funktioniert
tatsächlich ist die Verunsicherung aber
sehr sehr groß
die Art wie diese Preise aufgerufen
werden wenn wir gleich auch noch mal
besprechen Frau Silke Glöckner sie
sinken ja die Gaspreise hier schon aufs
Gerdes gesagt die Konsumlaune hält sich
auch etwas auf heute eine
Veröffentlichung eines
Marktforschungsinstituts wird dann
Bazooka Wumms und doppelbums schon na
der Doppel Wumms der muss ja erst noch
implementiert werden also da ist es
glaube ich die Ankündigung von ja das
wäre glaube ich sehr
hoffnungsvoll gedacht diese Marktpreise
vom Gast jetzt runtergehen das ist zwar
schön aber glaube ich auch vielleicht
ein kurzfristiger Effekt vor der
Heizperiode aber natürlich wirken die
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen die die jetzt
schon gemacht wurden die
energiepreispauschale natürlich hilft
das schon
der Staat mobilisierte im Moment alles
was an Flüssigkeit also vor allem Geld
auf dem Markt ist was passiert
eigentlich wenn das nicht reicht also
wenn wir mit dieser Bazooka dieser
sprichwörtlich nur einen Schuss frei
haben oder wenn es nur ein
schussmunition gibt
das ist ja genau die Frage ob es nur ein
schussmunition gibt wir haben ja schon
das dritte entlassungspaket jetzt am
Start das heißt es spricht theoretisch
erstmal nichts dagegen dass man auch
noch ein viertes auflegt bekommen wir
vielleicht gleich noch dazu wo wir mit
der Staatsverschuldung mittlerweile
stehen ich glaube das ist auch ein
viertes Paket theoretisch noch möglich
wäre wenn man jetzt feststellt dass die
drei nicht ausreichen
Marktwirtschaft und Staatseingriff das
sind ja ganz natürliche Gegenspieler
auch keine unanständige Feststellung
dass die aktuelle Krise vom Markt
geregelt wird dass würden sie aber
trotzdem nicht behaupten oder geregelt
werden kann sie könnte in wesentlich
stärkerem Ausmaß zum Start geregelt vom
Markt geregelt werden und Staat und
Marktwirtschaft sind auch überhaupt
nicht die Gegenspieler als die sie immer
stilisiert werden auch wir als erklärte
Freunde der Marktwirtschaft sind
ausdrücklich für einen starken Staat und
für Regeln und für einen festen Rahmen
und da muss der Staat natürlich wenn
jemand aus dem Rahmen rausgeht oder
Regeln verletzt muss der Staat auch
eingreifen aber was wir nicht wollen und
das haben wir in diesen Tagen und
Monaten natürlich reichlich ist das der
Staat selber die Regeln ignoriert außer
kraftsitz oder dass er sich als
Mitspieler am Markt betätigt und dass er
nur auf Vorschriften und die regismus
setzt und nicht auf marktvertraut zum
Beispiel was die Zertifikate betrifft
beim
klimaschutzer der Inflation ich meine
jetzt nicht das was die Ausgaben des
Staates angehen was Christian Lindner
dann gesagt hat so eine generell die
Politik mit Verursacher der Inflation
ist die Staat massiv mit Verursacher der
Inflation die Inflation ist seit Jahren
die die brauchte nur ein Punkt um sich
ab um zu entstehen aber wenn so viel
Geld unterwegs ist auch was die EZB
gemacht hat das war klar dass das kommt
es war nur die Frage wann und aus
welchem Anlass auch vielleicht nicht so
stark aber der Staat ist der Verursacher
ein Stück weit und der Staat ist auch
massiv Profiteur der Inflation natürlich
hat Herr Lindner recht beim Start
Gehälter steigen im öffentlichen Dienst
auch Baukosten für den Staat steigen ist
ganz klar aber auf der anderen Seite der
Staat hat in diesem Jahr eine
Entschuldung um 200 Milliarden Euro bei
8% Inflation in diesem Jahr 200
Milliarden Euro fallen einfach mal weg
Inflation hilft Schuldner und das gilt
vor allem für den Staat und
Steuermehreinnahmen sind auch da
insofern ist das Interesse die Inflation
einzugrenzen beim Start nicht ganz so
groß wie es mir wünschen würde der wird
aber sehr viel mehr für den
Schuldendienst bezahlen müssen aber wie
gesagt den Aspekt sprechen wir gleich an
also entlastungspakete haben wir auf den
Weg gebracht
Steuersenkungen oder Nachlässe oder
vorübergehende Steuersenkungen
energiezuschüsse
Inflationsausgleich wenn man das jetzt
mal alles in Gänse ansieht Frau
siegelglöckner
sind das sind alles sinnvolle Maßnahmen
gewesen
oder gibt es da welche wo sie sagen nee
also das war falsch oder wird sich als
falsch herausstellen ja es gibt
natürlich so das eine ist sind Maßnahmen
die man ganz ganz dringend machen muss
damit eine Wirtschaft irgendwie
durchkommt damit Unternehmen überleben
und Haushalte ihre Rechnung zahlen
können und andere Maßnahmen haben
vielleicht auch noch weitere politische
Ziele und also da hatten wir im Sommer
glaube ich mit dem Tankrabatt oder auch
natürlich mit dem 9-euro-ticket wo
befördert wurde dass dass man im
öffentlichen Nahverkehr nutzt natürlich
auch noch andere Ziele befolgt also ob
das optimal effizient war um uns jetzt
nur durch diese Krise zu bringen ist
eine Frage aber als Finanzpolitik darf
man ja vielleicht auch noch andere Ziele
verfolgen
wenn man das jetzt grundsätzlich
volkswirtschaftlich sieht der
holverscheid kann man sagen viel hilft
in dem Fall viel ich glaube in dem Fall
schon vor allem muss es in dem Fall
schnell gehen schnell heißt aber
gleichzeitig immer auch nicht besonders
präzise man hat sozusagen Streuverluste
aber ich glaube die Alternative die sich
jetzt hinzusetzen und monatelang
irgendwelche Konzepte auszuarbeiten die
dann sehr viel gezielter wirken und man
dann dadurch vielleicht auch die ein
oder andere Milliarde einspart das wäre
in dem Fall glaube ich die schlechtere
Variante gewesen weil es doch die
Preisentwicklung beispielsweise bei Gas
auch bei Benzin und bei anderen Dingen
doch so extrem war dass man glaube ich
vor allem schnell helfen musste das eine
ist die politische Einschätzung und die
Einordnung das andere ist die praktische
Auswirkung deswegen haben wir sie ja
auch eingeladen ja hier schon ausge
mit welchen Hilfsmaßnahmen da gab es ja
schon eine ganze Reihe die sind zum Teil
ja schon angelegt worden sind für die
corona-pandemie die Bewältigung der
corona-pandemie mit welchen
Hilfsmaßnahmen sind sie denn bisher
unterstützt worden hat sie schon alles
erreicht an Unterstützung an staatlicher
Förderung ganz unterschiedliche Art die
ihnen zusteht
also ich muss unterscheiden zwischen ja
wieder Fachmann sagen würde rückzahlbar
und nicht rückzahlbaren
ist ein geschenktes Geld auf gut deutsch
gesagt das andere ist ein Kredit wir
haben tatsächlich als Skala und als
schwesterunternehmer noch ein
Schwesterunternehmen Thüringen in Hessen
beide Töpfe möchte ich sie mal nennen
versucht in Anspruch zu nehmen
rückzahlbar heißt in der Regel dann das
über die KfW eine Verbürgung vorgenommen
wird dass sie also nicht so hohe
sicherheitsstellen müssen damit
tatsächlich ein Kredit in Anspruch
genommen und zahlen den jetzt seit
diesem Jahr auch wieder ab das ist also
eine klassische
corona-kredit Hilfsleistung
das zweite was wir tatsächlich auch
beantragt haben sind die sogenannten
Überbrückungshilfen die kommen auch noch
aus der corona-zeit
da kann ich das Argument was jetzt
gerade in der Runde aufkam nicht ganz
teilen dass wir da möglichst schnell
unterwegs waren ich gebe ein konkretes
Beispiel die letzte
überbrückungshilfezahlung die wir jetzt
erhalten haben
ist ohne eine Rückfrage bewilligt worden
und jetzt kommt das große ABER man hat
sich sechs Monate Zeit gelassen das
heißt zwischen Antragsstellung und
Auszahlung für einen mittleren
sechsstelligen Betrag das klingt jetzt
viel ist aber bei 400 Mitarbeitern sage
ich mal dann am Ende des Tages doch für
die Zeit
überschaubar braucht eine Bewilligung
dann sechs Monate dass Ihre Liquidität
beeinträchtigt diese
Verzögerung
ich denke was wir in der corona-zeit
gelernt haben ist dass die Programme
insgesamt zu
langatmig aufgesetzt waren und auch
immer noch sind um damit tatsächlich die
konkrete Situation zu überstehen auch
für die neueste Entwicklung die ja durch
den Überfall auf die Ukraine zwar nicht
verursacht aber beschleunigt worden ist
das können sie so sagen also ganz
konkret ist ja das Energiekosten
dämpfungsprogramm aufgesetzt worden das
ist sozusagen die die Vorstufe gewesen
jetzt zu den Empfehlungen der
gaspreiskommission für Unternehmen
und da hat man sich beispielsweise an
Listen orientiert für Unternehmen die
teilnehmen dürfen die doch sehr an der
Realität vorbei gegangen sind das heißt
der Bäcker durfte nicht beantragen aber
dafür der Tapetenhersteller und der
seilhersteller
sehen uns deswegen ja aufgefallen dass
er gesagt Ihre Branche weil die ja sehr
stark auf Gaslieferungen angewiesen sie
werden vor einigen Monaten einen
Kollegen von ihnen also aus einer
anderen etwas anderen Branche
glasherstellungen in Oberfranken da ist
das Problem ähnlich jetzt hat er
Versorger in gekündigt zum Jahresende
gibt es denn für sie noch eine
Möglichkeit irgendwo anders Gasherd zu
bekommen also die Situation hat sich in
den letzten Wochen schon deutlich
verbessert das heißt also gerade so
diese politische Einflussnahme die wir
eben auch hier schon angedeutet haben
die sorgt momentan auch für eine
Beruhigung der Märkte und die sorgt
schon auch dafür dass seitens der
Versorger also der Händler selbst
fördern tut ja kein deutsches
Unternehmen im Augenblick in
nennenswerten Maße also der der Händler
eine Bereitschaft besteht auch wieder
Verträge einzugehen
die Bedingungen sind gelegene gesagt
haarsträumend das heißt also selbst
etablierte Stadtwerke die in komplett
staatlicher also kommunaler
Eigentümerschaft sind fordern jetzt
Bürgschaften fordern Kautionen fordern
Vorkassen die durchaus mal den Viertel
eines Jahresverbrauchs umfassen und das
ist natürlich für ein Unternehmen was 20
Prozent seiner Gesamtkosten im Jahr für
Gas ausgegeben hat vor der Krise ja
schon dicker Brocken wenn man sich
anzieht was unternehmen jetzt gerade für
Probleme haben in unterschiedlicher
Intensität muss man sagen auch
Privathaushalte je nach Einkommenslage
hilft da die gaspreisbremse
die da jetzt dass es eine Einmalzahlung
Dezember möglicherweise ab Januar dann
eine
gaspreisbremse die wirksam ist zu 80%
zumindestens eine verbilligten Gaspreis
ermöglicht ich habe starke Zweifel dran
aber wenn wenn da irgendwas kommt in der
Richtung und wenn man da anfängt
staatlicherseits herumzufuhrwerken dann
sollte man es mindestens so tun dass es
Anreize auch weiterhin gibt es Gas
einzusparen und unter den früheren
Verbrauch zu kommen ähnlich bei den bei
dem wo alle einig scheinen dass man
gezielt bei den Bedürftigen besonders
hilft aber dann beim Wohngeld weiter die
Heizungskosten voll überweist da ist
kein Anreiz zum Sparen also da muss da
muss schon ein bisschen was passieren es
muss auch Anreize aus Klimaschutzgründen
wie aus ökonomischen Gründen zum Sparen
geben und man muss auch mal das traut
sich leider kein Politiker man muss
schon auch mal die Frage stellen nach 15
guten Jahren
dass man differenziert betrachtet wir
hören im Moment immer nur die besonders
betroffenen klar die auch vielleicht
gezielte Hefe brauchen wir hören wie
schlimm der externe Schock ist wie groß
die Ausnahmesituation das haben wir bei
Corona auch schon gehört es gibt auch
jedes Jahr irgendwo eine
Ausnahmesituation und ich nehme mal nur
die Hotels die haben 15 Jahre lang ein
rekorddergebnis ein Rekordjahr nach dem
anderen gehabt haben vor zehn Jahren
noch den ermäßigten Mehrwertsteuersatz
gekriegt und ihre Marge ausgebaut so und
kaum ist bei Corona mal ein bisschen was
passiert und wurde weniger gereist war
das Geschrei groß nach dem Staat also
irgendwo wenn die Leute man hat es auch
bei der Flut gesehen wenn die Leute
sparen und nicht mehr die
Versicherungsprämien für Flut
überflutungsschutz zahlen oder wenn Sie
den Blitzableiter nicht erneuern dann
ist ein Blitz der einschlägt zwar immer
noch ein externer Schock für den sie
nichts können aber man kann sich schon
fragen ob da eigentlich wirklich alles
getan wird in der Vorbereitung auch um
nicht im Staat zu allzu leicht zu Hilfe
zu benötigen also es wird viel nach dem
Start gerufen der Staat kann es gar
nicht alles leisten insofern müssen wir
da ein bisschen genauer hingucken ja
vielleicht kurz darauf noch ein bisschen
eingehen also vielleicht kann der Status
nicht alles leisten es ist tatsächlich
eine sehr sehr herausfordernde Situation
aber nur um das nochmal zu verdeutlichen
die Größenordnung wir haben einen
Gaspreis der am Markt um das Zehnfache
gestiegen ist also selbst wenn ja aber
es kommt auch auf die Ausgangsbasis an
sie können sogar auf mehr kommen nehmen
wir achtfach selbst wenn man als
Unternehmen vorausschauend unterwegs war
selbst wenn man als Haushalt
zurückgelegt hat wie soll das gehen also
deswegen ich glaube es redet niemand
davon dass man komplett einspar abreizer
abschafft ich meine der Vorschlag der
jetzt für Haushalte im Raum steht der
würde immer noch zu einer Verdopplung
führen das Gaspreises im Vergleich zum
zum Vorkrisen-Niveau aber dass man
diesen zehnfachen Preis auf die
Wirtschaft runter Rauschen lässt und
dass das irgendwie sinnvoll ist
das finde ich schwer nachvollziehbar und
deswegen also da greift der Staat jetzt
ein aber auch ziemlich aktiv um die
Inflation zu senken deswegen ist mich
eigentlich gewundert hat dass sie gesagt
haben der tut gerade nicht genug also
wollen sie das noch weiter gesenkt wird
oder dass der Gaspreis weiter gesenkt
wird Staat tut nicht genug um um die
Inflation zu senken die Inflation kommt
aus den Energiepreisen raus denn das ist
sechs Prozent der Inflation sagen andere
kommen aus ganz anderen Dingen und die
Energiepreise sind nur ein Teil und die
Inflation kommt vor allem auch aus der
jahrelangen Politik der Europäischen
Zentralbank und weiter zu viel Geld im
Umlauf haben und insofern wenn der Staat
immer mehr Geld ausschüttet wirkt er
auch prozyklisch wie man so schön sagt
als er beschleunigt auch seinerseits
noch ein Stück weit die Inflation
insofern dass man beim Gas über
hilfsmechanismen gezielt reden kann ist
ja das eine das haben wir auch nicht
ausgeschlossen und dass der
gaspreisschock wenn es eine
Vervielfachung ist ein bisschen groß ist
aber wir tun nur das eine wir nehmen
frisches Geld in die Hand was Politiker
immer gerne tun geben das aus helfen
meistens mit der Gießkanne aber
gleichzeitig zu gucken dass der Gaspreis
auch sinkt wir haben unter
niedersächsischen Boden haben wir Gas
für Jahre liegen aber da geht keiner
Ranger
gesagt dass gestern den Rotterdam der
Gas quasi verschenkt worden ist wir
haben die Speicher voll ich glaube 70
Flüssiggas Tanker liegen auf Rede vor
den europäischen Küsten
wann kommt dieser dieser wirklich stark
gesungen der Gaspreis der wirklich
leider Nulllinie ist eigentlich bei den
Verbrauchern und bei den Unternehmen an
der wird schon der wird schon in den
großen Topf sozusagen das ist ja eine
wie Frau siegelglücken eben schon
zurecht gesagt hat das ist ja nur eine
Momentaufnahme der wird in den großen
Topf schon eingehen und das wird sich
auch dämpfend auswirken ich fürchte aber
genau wie Sie dass wir noch längst nicht
über den Berg sind sondern dass das ein
vorübergehendes Phänomen ist das Wetter
ist extrem warm zur Zeit für für Ende
Oktober das heißt wir brauchen viel
weniger Gas als wir vielleicht zu
anderen in anderen Jahren um die
Jahreszeit gebraucht hätten also ich
glaube dass das jetzt auch genauso
schnell wie in die andere Richtung
bewegen kann deswegen bin ich doch sehr
skeptisch ob das schon das Licht am
Horizont ist auf dass wir alle warten
gut bei Ihnen ist es ja so dass das der
Klima unabhängig ist sie brauchen immer
Gas sie brauchen immer viel Gas man
rechnen Sie damit einer möglichen
Entlastung aufgrund des der
Preisentwicklung also wir gehen davon
aus dass ohne staatlichen Eingriff ein
Mittel die frustiger Preis ungefähr bei
10 Cent im Großhandel das heißt an der
Börse wäre das ist so unser Annahme
im Vergleich dazu das was jetzt die
gaspreiskommission empfiehlt sind 7 Cent
vor ungefähr anderthalb Jahren hatten
wir einen Preis der lag in der
Größenordnung 2 zweieinhalb Cent also
wir gehen davon aus dass diese
Vervierfachung schon aufgrund des Themas
Transportkosten lng-kapazität und so
weiter und so fort längerfristig sein
wird bei den Märkten funktioniert das
Ganze so dass das für die nächsten Jahre
mit vorwärts und Futures gehandelt wird
das heißt sie haben finanzterivate womit
letztendlich ganz platt im Grunde als
wenn sie Weizen oder Stahl
spekulieren möchten in der Zukunft also
handeln können dass sie da ganz grob
sagen können die Preise sind lieber zum
Vorgänger ungefähr 30 Prozent niedriger
da muss man aber wirklich mit
einbeziehen dass die
handelswerte für das nächste Jahr weit
jenseits der 10 Cent liegen das heißt
weit oberhalb liegen also bei 14 16 18
Cent und demzufolge in 24 in der Region
10 Cent und dann vielleicht in 25 und 25
bei 7 Cent also wenn die Aussichten
durchwachsen sind sagen wir es mal so
kann die Politik da eigentlich mehr tun
als nur zu reagieren mit klaren Ansagen
mit klaren Konzepten jetzt auch nicht
nur für die nächsten Wochen und Monate
die sicherlich hart werden sondern eben
auch für eine mittelfristige Zukunft
fehlt ist das ein Defizit der Politik na
ich glaube man muss die Krise erst mal
schrittweise angehen und die Blutungen
stellen wenn der Patient in der
Notaufnahme ist und da sind wir gerade
an dem Punkt wir waren uns alle einig
dass es irgendwie nicht schnell genug
gehen kann auf der anderen Seite
wahnsinnig schwer ist die Programme gut
aufzulegen deswegen darauf muss man sich
jetzt konzentrieren aber klar dann ist
sehr sehr wichtig zu gucken wie es
mittelfristig weitergeht und auch als
Politik sich zu überlegen wo ist mit der
energieintensiven deutschen Wirtschaft
hingeht wir werden höhere Preise haben
in den USA ist das Gas sehr viel
billiger und wenn man die Frage stellt
wie kommt dieses ganze Geld zurück oder
wie geht das auf dann kommt es darauf an
dass man eine gut produzierende
Wirtschaft hat und wenn man denkt dass
da manches hier nicht mehr so
wettbewerbsfähig ist dann ist das die
ganz ganz große Herausforderung und ja
also sobald die Blutung gestillt ist die
unmittelbare müsste man unbedingt
schauen wie es da weitergeht und
wahrscheinlich in enger Abstimmung mit
der Wirtschaft selbst wenn das ganz
schwierig ist Start und Wirtschaft
zusammen sich überlegen was ein guter
Weg vorwärts ist wenn unverscheid noch
mal so eine große Krise auftaucht wie
jetzt in den letzten Jahren erst Corona
dann Inflation das hat ja wie gesagt
verschiedene Gründe gehabt hatte noch
zum Teil mit Corona zu tun mit dem
Überfall auf die Ukraine der Krieg
dessen Ausgang ungewiss ist wenn noch
eine dritte großkrise käme würden wir
dann pleite gehen
dann wurde wenn dann würde die ganze
Welt pleite gehen weil wir sind ja nicht
die einzigen die das Problem haben ich
glaube nicht dass wir pleite gehen
würden es ist ja so dass wir zwar eine
Staatsschuld haben die von die für
normale Bürger mit 2,4 2,5 Billionen
Euro
praktisch unvorstellbar ist
gemessen am Bruttoinlandsprodukt sind
wir aber unter den großen
Industriestaaten haben wir die mit
Abstand geringste Staatsverschuldung wir
sind glaube ich weit davon entfernt nach
wie vor soll es kein Plädoyer sein dass
dramatisch auszuweiten aber sind glaube
ich weit von dem Punkt entfernt wo
Deutschland am Rande der Staats Pleite
stünde die Amerikaner haben
eine Staatsverschuldung verdoppelt so
hoch ist wie wir wenn man es eben am an
der Wirtschaftsleistung misst andere
europäische Staaten haben auch deutlich
höhere Werte also ohne dass jetzt zu
beschönigen zu wollen und zu sagen hier
gibt's gar kein Problem sind wir doch
von der staatsbreite sehr weit entfernt
selbst wenn noch eine Krise käme
von der Staatspleite sind wir
tatsächlich weltweit entfernter Start
hat viele Möglichkeiten sich auf
frisches Geld zu beschaffen das wird er
auch wahrscheinlich zunehmend tun über
Steuererhöhungen versteckt oder offene
ich teile nicht die Zahl mit den 2,5
Billionen das ist nur ein kleiner Teil
der Wahrheit das Start bilanziert nicht
mal ein Fünftel seiner Staatsschulden
ehrlich es gibt versteckte Schulden die
Beamtenpension ohne Rückstellungen viele
andere Zusagen ohne Rückstellungen wenn
man das alles addiert sind vorbei 14
Billionen das sind 14.000 Milliarden
Euro die auf der jungen Generation
liegen und das wie die Ökonomen sagen
kein free lunch also nichts freigibt und
nichts umsonst gibt und wo entlastet
wird auch belastet wird irgendjemand
muss es zahlen und es werden die
Jüngeren sein und deswegen bin ich
skeptisch bei allem was jetzt zu
schulden führt und deswegen ärgert mich
auch der doppelwumms ein Stück weit weil
wenn ich die Programme denn auch die
Bazooka schon wenn ich die Programme der
letzten Jahre angucke ich sehe das auf
der einen Seite in kraftvolles Signal
gesendet werden soll psychologisch ist
ja alles wunderbar aber es ist eben auch
so dass der Inflation der Zahlen auch
die Situation der Preise folgt und wenn
heute Politiker an 40 Milliarden
Programm verkünden dann wird es ja nicht
mal mehr in den Medien abgedruckt weil
das hinter dem doppelwumms und hinter
anderen zurück bleibt also die Zahlen
werden immer astronomischer die
Maßnahmen werden immer grenzenloser und
der Schuldenberg steigt und bei den 14
Billionen ist noch nicht mal
eingerechnet die Schattenhaushalte der
Ampel wo ja tausend verschiedene
Töpfchen noch auch noch gesondert
versteckt sogenannte Sondervermögen also
irgendjemand muss es zahlen wenn wir
aber über eine Bilanz reden dann sollten
wir über beide Seiten der Bilanz reden
weil was dann wichtig ist ist wie sich
Vermögen im Verhältnis zu Verschuldung
entwickelt und das ist glaube ich jetzt
die ganz ganz große Frage also mit all
diesen Schulden die wir aufnehmen mit
den 200 Milliarden was passiert da auf
der vermögenszeit wenn die Unternehmen
uns alle pleite gehen haben wir ein
großes Problem
ich sehe eine große Herausforderung
darin das glaube ich unser
Bildungssystem in der corona-zeit sehr
gelitten hat unser größter Posten auf
der vermögensseite ist human-kapital das
sind die jungen gut ausgebildeten Leute
die Nachkommen die unsere Fachkräfte
sind und diese Seite müssen wir jetzt
meiner Sicht nach ziemlich ernsthaft
angucken und dann können wir das
vielleicht auch in in Vergleich setzen
sonst wird es etwas einseitig und als
junge Generation hat man um die Seite
ein bisschen Angst auch jetzt gerade
weil es so viel um es kurzfristige geht
aber wo bleiben die Investitionen und
die steigen zum Beispiel mit der
Inflation nicht mit also da bleibt die
Linie konstant das heißt wir werden de
facto weniger investieren aber da muss
ich auch entgegen zu den Investitionen
neue Schulden werden immer mit
Investitionsbedarf begründet und immer
mit den Fällen wo es schlüssig und
einleuchtend ist also Bildung versteht
jeder ich auch
Straßen versteht auch jeder wenn man
bestimmte Brücken und unschlaglöcher
anguckt das versteht jeder damit werden
die Schulden immer begründet in den
guten Jahren haben wir massiv Gelder
gespart wegen der niedrig der Staat hat
massiv Schuldendienst eingespart und wir
haben massive Steuer Mehreinnahmen
gehabt 2012 bis 2019
unglaubliches Geld mehr gehabt zur
Verfügung und größere Spielräume gehabt
und wo sind die hingeflossen eben nicht
in die Bildung eben nicht ausreichend in
die Infrastruktur sondern in Renten
Geschenke und insofern deswegen bin ich
so ein bisschen kritisch wenn immer
gesagt wird das sind doch gute Ziele und
dafür können wir doch neue Schulden
aufnehmen es ist eben nicht gemacht
worden und auch wenn wir jetzt einen
neuen dreifach-wumms machen dann würden
wieder zwei Drittel oder drei Viertel in
die gleichen rentenprojekte fließen und
eben nicht ankommen bei der Bildung und
bei der jungen Generation gesagt Bildung
Straßenbau versteht jeder leider
versteht nicht jeder Finanzpolitik und
das ist ja bedauerlich deswegen müssen
wir das hier nochmal
aufklärerisch behandeln
der O-Ton vom Eingang Christian hinter
der gesagt steigen die Steuereinnahmen
durch die Inflation höhere Preise höre
Umsatzsteuer ist nachvollziehbar es
steigen aber auch die
Staatsausgaben die natürlich auch oft
konstruktive Leistungen sind Gehälter
die auch steigen die auch
inflationsgetrieben steigen durch die
Inflation noch weiter steigen das heißt
das wie so 0 summenspiel bleibt da
überhaupt noch was übrig wenn der
Bundesfinanzminister gleichzeitig sagt
dass das was man den Bürger durch
Inflation aus die Tasche zieht das
kriegt auch wieder zurück der
Bundesfinanzminister hat die Rechnung ja
heute selber aufgemacht die haben wir
die 126 Milliarden erwähnt die wir
theoretisch wenn alles alle Annahmen der
steuerschützer Stimmen bis 2026
zusätzlich haben und da hat dann gleich
eine Rechnung aufgemacht was all das was
jetzt schon an Entlastung beschlossen
ist zum Beispiel Inflationsausgleich
immer das zusammenrechnet dann kann man
bei 116 17 raus das heißt von den 126
ist 90% oder 95% schon wieder
verfrühstückt also insofern ist das
schon so eine Art Nullsummenspiel dass
sie gerade erwähnt haben
gerade bei dem Thema Verschuldung haben
sie gesagt also so ganz dramatisch sie
das nicht jetzt ist es ja so heute er
hat ja gleichzeitig auch die Europäische
Zentralbank den Zins erhöht um 0,75% das
ist auch eine ganze Menge auch wenn das
zunächst mal wenig klingt damit bekämpft
man oder will man die Inflation
bekämpfen also die gute Sache aber
gleichzeitig werden alle die die Geld
brauchen
in die Mangel genommen der die
Privathaushalte zum Beispiel die die
bauen wollen aber auch der
Schuldendienst des Bundeshaushaltes
steigt der gewaltig ist im letzten Jahr
bei vier Milliarden Euro gewesen das ist
ganz wenig nächstes Jahr wird er schon
30 Milliarden betragen aber da ja die
Schulden steigen und die Zinsen
wahrscheinlich auch dass die Jahre
danach noch sehr viel mehr werden ist
das nicht eine Gefahr dieser steigende
diese steigende Verschuldung schon
allein durch die Kreditzinsen die der
Stadt bezahlen muss
diese Zinszahlungen sind im Vergleich zu
ein bisschen mehr Steuereinnahmen
verschwinden gering also das ist glaube
ich nicht die entscheidende Frage
da wird man mit ein bisschen besserer
Wirtschaftspolitik das locker wett
machen können also ich meine der Bund
hat nächstes Jahr Steuereinnahmen
prognostiziert glaube ich von 370
Milliarden da kommen ein bisschen mehr
oben drauf und schon sind die die
Zinszahlungen ziemlich marginal also da
sehe ich nicht das ganz große Problem
bei den Zinserhöhungen der Europäischen
Zentralbank ich sehe sie aber trotzdem
sehr sehr kritisch
und zwar
ist das eigentlich ziemlich inkorrent
mit dem was die was die Finanzpolitik
macht die Finanzpolitik gibt momentan
viel Geld aus um die Wirtschaft zu
stützen um Privatleuten das Einkommen zu
stabilisieren und Unternehmen zu
stabilisieren weil sie sagen wir haben
gerade so ein Kostenschock von außen wir
kommen sonst nicht klar und die
Europäische Zentralbank sagt wir haben
hier zu viel Nachfrage zu viel Feuer
unter der Wirtschaft deswegen müssen wir
Kredite teurer machen damit weniger
ausgegeben wird und deswegen ziehen wir
die Zinsen an das ist komplett
gegenläufige Politik und EZB hat heute
sogar gesagt ja wir müssen die Nachfrage
runterbringen die Politik macht das
Gegenteil die sagt die Nachfrage also
wir müssen die stabilisieren ich sehe
das wie die Politik weil die Gehälter in
Deutschland also real Löhne sind -4,4
Prozent und das geht noch weiter also da
ist ein massiver negativer Schock aber
ich sehe nicht wie die EZB da etwas
Sinnvolles beiträgt die Nachfrage
sowieso am Boden es ist ein
energiepreisschock und mit höheren
Zinsen senken sie kein Gaspreis
wir haben jetzt über Ihr Unternehmen und
die speziellen Probleme gesprochen reden
wir mal über ihren sozialen Status sie
sind Unternehmer es wird nämlich immer
wieder als Möglichkeit der
Gegenfinanzierung um Schulden zu
begleichen um Löcher zu stopfen auch um
zu einer auch sozialen Symmetrie zu
einem sozialen Ausgleich zu mehr soziale
Gerechtigkeit zu kommen gefordert soll
ja eine Vermögensteuer eingeführt werden
die Erbschaftssteuerreform vor allem in
betrieblichen Bereich bei besonders
hohen Erbschaften da muss auch was
gemacht werden ist das etwas was sie
dann auch persönlich betrifft das was
ist ihre Position zu dieser Forderung
die ja immer wieder
erhoben wird im Zusammenhang mit all den
finanziellen Problemen die wir jetzt
schon besprochen haben also die Firma
carla hat nach fast 180 Jahren in 2020
Insolvenz angemeldet das heißt ich habe
das Unternehmen übernommen aus nein
Insolvenz raus mit dem klaren Anspruch
dort in Thüringen dauerhaft Porzellan zu
produzieren wir haben 50 Arbeitsplätze
gerettet und die in dauerhafte wirklich
auch sichere Arbeitsplätze umgewandelt
es besteht ein massiver
Investitionsbedarf und was wir dort
momentan jammern es kein Jammern auf
hohem Niveau also glücklicherweise
stellt sich bei mir eine Frage der
Nachfolge jetzt noch nicht unmittelbar
deswegen kann ich da tatsächlich solche
Themen Steuern zum Beispiel wenn sie
sagen sie haben sowieso sehr viele
finanzielle Verpflichtungen ja eine
Vermögenssteuer wird ich persönlich als
sehr sehr kritisch betrachten also da
bin ich tatsächlich dann jemand der
eher schauen würde wie findet
tatsächlich wenn ich so weit reingehen
ins Unternehmen wenn ich soweit ins
Eigentum gehe wie findet tatsächlich
vernünftige Unternehmensführung statt
wird am Standort investiert werden
vernünftige Löhne gezahlt werden
dauerhafte Arbeitsplätze garantiert
werden Umweltstandards eingehalten also
das wären Themen wo ich sage da tut man
wahrscheinlich auch um ein bisschen in
ihre Richtung zu schauen dauerhaft mehr
auf der Aktivseite
als wenn wir jetzt wieder in die
konsuktion gehen also alles was wir die
letzten drei Jahre gesehen haben war
kompletter Konsum von vorne bis hinten
auch einen neuen Euro Ticket mit dem am
Wochenende die Fahrten gemacht wurden
Konsum eine Bezuschussung von
Spritpreisen war am Ende Konsum also
nicht falsch verstehen 20 Cent mehr oder
weniger beim Spritpreis sind wichtig
dass man darüber redet aber ein
dauerhafter Verlust von Arbeitsplätzen
wenn wir jetzt gerade wieder über
energieintensive Industrie reden wo wer
über Berufe reden wo Menschen in
traditionellen Betrieben teilweise
jahrzehntelang schon arbeiten die das
gelernt haben also da steckt Passion
dahinter sie können den Wecker jetzt
nicht einfach auf den Arbeitsmarkt
schicken und sagen jetzt ab jetzt
verkaufst du die Deutsche Telekom und da
Festnetzanschlüsse also da steckt ja
auch was dahinter also das sind ja
Lebensläufe und jetzt einfach zu sagen
naja es ist woanders günstiger also mir
fällt das schwer
also die bei der bei den Steuern wir
haben in Deutschland in den letzten
guten Jahren schon das immer gesteigert
die Steuereinnahmen und zwar auch
deswegen weil wir die Steuern faktisch
erhöht haben ohne die Steuersätze zu
erhöhen wir haben eine rekordsteuerquote
und wenn man mal guckt wer zahlt
eigentlich die Steuern in Deutschland
die zehn Prozent die am meisten
verdienen zahlen 50% über 50%
Einkommensteuer 20% des gesamten
Mehrwertsteuer Aufkommens 70% des
gesamten Kirchensteuer Aufkommens die
Umverteilung findet statt über die
Steuern das ist auch richtig das schafft
auch sozialen Frieden aber es ist
wirklich reichlich Umverteilung und wenn
man jetzt noch mehr drauf sattelt wenn
sie können die Reichensteuer um 10%
erhöhen dann kriegen sie gerade mal
läppische 4 Milliarden ein
mehrwertsteuerpunkt sind 14 und die
Frage ist wo landen denn die Belastungen
am Ende wenn sie Steuern erhöhen
Einkommensteuer die Masse macht Kasse
sagt jeder Steuermann in der Mitte
kriegen sie am meisten Geld und dann
kann man natürlich sagen gut dann machen
wir halt ein bisschen Billard linke
Tasche rechte Tasche die heute wird
entlastet jetzt bei den ganzen
Hilfsmaßnahmen und wir ziehen ja nachher
wird das Geld aus der Tasche über die
Steuern erstens geht da wahnsinnig viel
auf dem Weg verloren und zweitens auch
weil Herr holverscheid vorhin gesagt hat
Nullsummenspiel
das ist von der startschicht
möglicherweise wenn Herr Lindner Recht
hat mit den Zahlen richtig
möglicherweise aus Sicht des Staates
aber aus Sicht der Menschen ist es nicht
richtig denn diejenigen die dafür zahlen
sind nicht die die das kriegen wenn wir
vor allem im unteren Bereich helfen und
das Ergebnis des immer wieder
kumulierten konzentrierten helfen sie im
unteren Bereich ist eben auch dass es
dass viele Jobs mit zweieinhalbtausend
2000 3000 Euro brutto gerade nicht
besetzt werden weil die Leute sagen es
ist attraktiver nicht zu arbeiten und
wir sind gehen noch weiter auf diesem
Weg und Wohngeld zu bekommen und die
Heizung voll zu bekommen anstatt die
ganzen Sozialversicherungsbeiträge zu
zahlen also das ist einmal die
Diskussion laufen lassen weil es
vermutlich eher im Studio noch andere
Überzeugungen gibt aber bitte also ich
glaube das in der Rechnung einiges fehlt
beispielsweise ich verstehe ihr Argument
dass sie sagen ich habe hier eine Firma
gerettet ich investiere es kann nicht
sein dass mir jetzt die Firma praktisch
über die Vermögenssteuer wieder
weggenommen wird das wäre wirklich
Wahnsinn trotzdem fehlt in ihrer Bilanz
Professor alphort
während der corona-krise sind die
privaten Vermögen explodiert geradezu
die Börsen sind in astronomische Höhen
gesprungen und da haben ganz viel Leute
sehr sehr viel Geld verdient und dass
man darüber nachdenkt zum Beispiel kann
man diese Leute diese Gewinne die dort
angefallen sind kann man die in
irgendeiner Form zu Finanzierung des
Allgemeinwohls heranziehen das finde ich
eine völlig legitime Diskussion
weil bislang oder ich muss andersrum
sagen wir haben ja wir wollen nach der
Leistungsfähigkeit besteuern und da ist
die Einkommensteuer eigentlich gar nicht
das richtige Instrument da zahle ich
nämlich schon wenn ich
Durchschnittsverdiener bin bin ich schon
in der Nähe der Spitzensteuersatz es ist
ein Riesenproblem wenn ich aber
sehr sehr viel Geld habe sehr viel
Vermögen aber auch geerbt habe und gar
nicht arbeitet dann zahle ich gar keine
Einkommensteuer das heißt hier gibt es
glaube ich einen Missverhältnis in der
in der Entwicklung der Vermögen die
durchaus
wo man größer drüber nachdenken muss wie
man wie man wie man damit umgeht und wie
man mit dieser Ungleichverteilung die
sich in jeder Krise noch weiter
verschärft umgeht ob die Vermögenssteuer
dann das richtige Instrument ist am Ende
darüber kann man streiten Präsident zum
Beispiel ähnlich besteuert werden wie
wie eine das wäre mal das allerkleinste
was man sofort machen könnte in der Tat
also ich glaube das dass wir diese sehr
ungleich Vermögensverteilung haben ist
genau ein Faktor der uns jetzt gerade so
angreifbar macht die weniger wohl haben
50 Prozent besitzen 0,7% des deutschen
Vermögens das heißt wir können eben
sowas wie ein eine energiepreisschock
nicht so einfach abfedern und das wäre
ja eigentlich viel besser ich glaube da
werden wir uns alle einig wenn die Leute
ein bisschen Geld auf dem Konto hätten
und ein bisschen klarkommen würden für
ein paar Monate dann würde auch in der
Politik nicht sofort die Hütte brennen
aber solange man diese
Ungleichverteilung hat kann man das eben
nicht so locker sagen ja nehmzeit vom
Konto also die 25 Prozent mit den
geringsten Einkommen die sparen 0 im
Monat und die haben auch während Corona
0 gespart während die oberen Einkommen
alle viel zurücklegen konnten und dann
ist man eben so in einer Situation wie
jetzt wo man ganz ganz schnell Programme
verabschieden muss für die man
eigentlich gar nicht das Werkzeug hat
es geht ja um Finanzpolitik die sehr
kompliziert ist das ist jetzt gar kein
Vorwurf an die Ampelkoalition sehr viel
mehr könnte man ihr ja den Vorwurf
machen dass in den vielen dieser Fragen
völlig zerstritten ist nicht nur bei
Atomen Laufzeitverlängerung oder bei der
Frage ob Chinesen im Hamburger Hafen
investieren dürfen sondern eben auch der
Frage wie die Finanzpolitik am
besten funktioniert ist in dieser Stelle
zerstrittenen Koalition erholverscheid
Finanzpolitik überhaupt noch möglich
kann überhaupt noch gelingen in dem
Sinne wie wir es jetzt im Moment
eigentlich bräuchten angesichts dieser
Krise
naja ich meine die Politik hat es ja
immerhin geschafft diese Pakete jetzt
aufzulegen sie wird auch ein Haushalt
aufstellen fürs kommende Jahr und ich
glaube sogar dass das momentan an dieser
Front sogar einigermaßen ruhig ist Herr
Lindner hat es geschafft sein
Inflationsausgleich also die kalte
Progression die er den Leuten ersetzen
will dass durchzusetzen die anderen
Parteien haben auch ihre
ihre Vorstellung zumindest teilweise
durchsetzen können insofern finde ich in
dem Punkt ist die Koalition vielleicht
sogar noch am wenigsten zerstritten da
gibt es ja andere Fälle wo das viele
eklatanter war in den letzten Tagen also
man muss die Klientelpolitik der drei
auf einen Nenner bringen irgendwo und
Kompromisse schmieden
das ist glaube ich die immer die Kunst
in einer Koalitionsregierung und ich
weiß auch gar nicht ob das immer
Klientelpolitik ist das ist auch so ein
Wort
wenn beispielsweise Herr Lindner sagt
ich will die Steuer Mehreinnahmen die
allein auf der Inflation auf die
Inflation beruhen die will ich den
Leuten zurückgeben dann finde ich das
jetzt keine besonders neoliberale oder
verachtenswerte Klientelpolitik sondern
das ist völlig in Ordnung
umgekehrt wenn die Grünen oder die SPD
irgendein Bedarf dort haben dass sie
sagen wir müssen den und den
Bevölkerungsgruppen helfen dann ist das
aus ihrer Sicht sind das eben Menschen
den den besonders geholfen werden müssen
auch weiß ich nicht ob man das als
Klientelpolitik bezeichnen kann also ich
würde sagen da gibt es andere Bereiche
wo sehr wo die Koalition sehr viel mehr
Nachholbedarf in Sachen Harmonie hat das
heißt wie weit ist das beschwerlich dann
oder beschwert es die Lösung unserer
Probleme und die Überwindung der Krise
dass die Ampelkoalition sich in vielen
Bereichen nicht einig ist
es macht es glaube ich manchmal
schwieriger Lösungen lange im Vorhinein
zu finden man braucht etwas politischen
Druck aber und lässt sich viel zu viel
Zeit aber ich teile Ihre Einschätzung ja
aber es ist auch gar nicht so leicht
also können sie in der momentanen
Situation
wo man wirklich jeden Tag im Gefühl
kriegen muss was passiert eigentlich mit
der Wirtschaft ich habe den Luxus dass
wir das den ganzen Tag anschauen von
allen Seiten das ist nicht trivial
da kann man nicht schon vor sechs
Monaten mit der Lösung fertig gewesen
sein also wir wissen auch alle nicht was
was passiert ist insofern sehe ich das
jetzt auch nicht als ich verstehe auch
beispielsweise Ihren Wunsch dass sie
sagen das müsste ich noch schneller
gehen dass die Hilfen bei den Leuten
ankommen völlig berechtigt nur ich will
jetzt die Politik hier nicht in bauschen
Boom verteidigen aber das ist natürlich
auch für die alles Neuland also die
diese Programme die wir da gerade
auflegen die hat noch nie eine eine
Regierung und auch eine Verwaltung als
eine Regierung politisch beschließen und
einer Verwaltung dann umsetzen müssen
das heißt
das fängt bei den einfachsten
IT-Problemen die es da teilweise an da
kann man jetzt auch lange darüber
diskutieren warum wir die IT-Probleme
überhaupt haben verdiene ich schon
beziehen dann hätten abstellen können
das stimmt alles aber Fakt ist dass die
ist auch gerade also es ist jedenfalls
nicht so geht man liegt ein Schalter um
und dann ist Geld bei den Leuten so
funktioniert halt nicht geht das mit ich
gehe das mit ich würde mir trotzdem
vielleicht teilweise etwas mehr
Klientelpolitik wie wir sie jetzt gerade
so ein bisschen Schmäh mäßig genannt
haben wünscht und ein paar Teilen also
es geht jetzt nicht nur um Leute die
möglichst wenig Steuern bezahlen sondern
es geht um eine wertfreie
Klientelpolitik jede Partei wird von
einem bestimmten wählergruppierung vor
allem gewählt um deren Interessen
durchzusetzen das ist zunächst mal eine
wertfreie Feststellung ich würde mir
mehr von dieser etwas
punktuelleren Logik wünschen also ich
würde mir wünschen dass wir wegkommen
von der Gießkanne ich würde mir wünschen
dass wir wegkommen davon zu versuchen
alles zu regeln wenn Sie das
Energiekosten dämpfungsprogramm nehmen
als konkretes Programm ist ja jetzt
abgelaufen da hatte das Merkblatt 60
Seiten
es war perfekt formuliert es hatte 60
Seiten was sie erreicht haben ist der
Statistiker sagt es gibt so ein Alpha
und betafehler also mit dem betafehler
vermeiden Sie dass ich jemand
unrechtmäßig bereichert mit dem
alpha-fehler da ist das Problem dass die
die eigentlich was bekommen sollten die
kriegen nichts am Ende haben sie genau
das erreicht das haben die nichts
bekommen die auch nichts bekommen
sollten und die anderen auch nicht aber
vielleicht können wir auch noch mal ganz
ganz konkret weil das auch angesprochen
wurde Abgeltungssteuer wir haben auf die
Diskussion über Vermögensteuer ich sehe
auch dass es bei den Vermögen natürlich
Unterschiede gibt klar das ist nicht so
wie bei den Einkommen wo wir Stabilität
haben die hat es gegeben es hat jetzt
auch mit dem abschmieren der Aktienkurse
auch entsprechende Verluste gegeben wenn
wir über Vermögenssteuer oder noch weit
über den wir haben keine Ausgangslage
nicht dass die Kapitalerträge anfängt da
muss man sagen ja 25% plus wird immer
vergessen Kirchensteuer so wenn jetzt
über diese Themen geredet wird dann
klopfen sich viele immer hämisch auf die
Schenkel denken an Frau Klatten und
Herrn Hopp und sagen
wir können ja auch ein bisschen mehr
beitragen was aber vergessen wird zum
Beispiel bei jungen Leuten wir lesen
jetzt immer in der Zeitung dass so viele
jüngere Leute und zwar völlig zurecht
weil die genau wissen sie kriegen von
der Rente selber nichts mehr raus so wie
die Rentenversicherung konstruiert ist
das junge Leute sagen sie kaufen sich
vielleicht mal ein paar Aktien so und
dann setzen wir von 25% bei der
Dividende nehmen wir dann die 42 oder
was weiß ich was für ein junge Leute
nicht die ist ja keine Zweifel viele
müssen ja auch ihre Altersversorgung aus
versteuertem Einkommen bezahlen und
nicht nur aus Aktien ganz kurz ich bin
seit nicht wenigen Jahren Journalist ich
kann mich erinnern dass zu Beginn meiner
journalistischen
Biografie schon über den Abbau von
Bürokratie gesprochen worden ist das
jetzt ganz dringend notwendig ist er ja
schon aufgere jetzt gerade ein Beispiel
genannt
ich habe meine Befürchtung die gleiche
Zeit geht noch mal ins Landes
möglicherweise doch nicht so viel
passiert was ist warum funktioniert sich
meine sie haben für die SPD in einem
Bundestagswahlkreis kandidiert sind dann
ja auch wenn sie irgendwann mal gewählt
werden in den Bundestag dafür auch
verantwortlich
möglicherweise schon demnächst warum
funktioniert das nicht in der in der
Politik muss erstmal sagen wieso das so
dringend ist weil ich glaube wenn wir
über Dinge reden die gerade nicht
funktionieren dann haben wir da ein
großes Problem bei Ökonomen gehört
gerade so zur Vorrede wenn man irgendwo
einen Vortrag hält das Wichtigste was
wir jetzt tun müssen ist erneuerbare
Energien ausbauen machen wir natürlich
auch stimmt nicht Windräder die Hälfte
der Auktionen also wo das Volumen in der
letzten Auktion nicht versteigert bei
Solar gibt es auch ein Problem ein Grund
ist wohl die große Bürokratie dauert
alles viel zu lang andere Länder haben
es runter bekommen wir schaffen es nicht
deswegen das ist mittlerweile wirklich
ein Thema das essentiell ist für für
unseren zukünftigen Wohlstand wieso
klappt es nicht gibt sicher mehrere
Gründe aber ein Punkt ist meiner Ansicht
nach schon auch dass man eben versucht
auch als Bundesregierung alles bis ins
Detail zu regulieren wir haben einen
Klimaschutz vor kl transformationsfonds
der hat endlos viele Programme drin oft
mehrere Programme fürs gleiche Ding
Kommunen haben ganze Abteilungen um
diese Förderprogramme zu verstehen aber
so hat man als Haushälter natürlich
immer gut Kontrolle darüber wo das Geld
hingeht anstatt dass man sagt kommunig
ist das Geld Zielerreichung und die du
wolltest
necessieren
genehmigungsinnovationsbürokratie müssen
wir massiv abbauen
sozialstaatsbürokratie finde ich sogar
positiv denn Bürokratie im Sozialstaat
und Einzelfallprüfung ist Gerechtigkeit
da sollte man nicht an der falschen
Stelle sparen wollte ich triumphierend
verkünden dass es im Bereich Bürokratie
möglicherweise durchaus interessens
Konvergenzen in dieser Diskussionsrunde
gibt und wollte sie nämlich
überschließen muss wir sind nämlich am
Ende aber gut das ist ein Thema wie
gesagt begleitet mich seit Jahrzehnten
alle anderen auch ich bedanke mich für
die Diskussion bei Philipper Siegl
Glöckner bei professor Michael eilford
bei Daniel ja schon und bei Klaus
unwahrschein Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer morgen ein sendeter Hinweis
die angekündigte Rede des
Bundespräsidenten zur Lage Nation um 11
Uhr live beim Phoenix und ab 15 Uhr der
CSU Parteitag beides morgen bei Phoenix
aktuelles und weiteres jetzt bei Phoenix
der Tag mit Maja Weber darin unter
anderem noch mal die Steuerschätzung
aber auch die Sitzung des
UN-Sicherheitsrats bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]